Moderation: Guten Morgen, alle zusammen. Ähm, können wir anfangen? Ist jeder da?
[Gemurmel im Hintergrund, Stühle werden gerückt]
Klaus: Moment noch, ich suche gerade meine Unterlagen. Hat jemand einen Stift?
Thomas: Hier, ich hab einen. Moderation, können wir kurz warten? Ich hole mir noch einen Kaffee.
Moderation: [seufzt] Okay, aber bitte schnell. Wir haben heute viel zu besprechen.
[Pause, Geräusche von Papierrascheln und Kaffeetasse]
Moderation: Also gut, fangen wir an. Zuerst die Verkaufszahlen der letzten Woche. Sabine, kannst du uns ein Update geben?
Sabine: Ja, sicher. Moment, ich öffne die Datei... Okay, also, wir haben einen leichten Anstieg in den Verkäufen gesehen, besonders in der Region Süd.
Peter: [unterbricht] Entschuldigung, ich bin gerade erst reingekommen. Worum geht's nochmal genau?
Moderation: [genervt] Peter, wir sprechen über die Verkaufszahlen. Das hatten wir doch letzte Woche schon besprochen.
Peter: Ah ja, stimmt. Sorry, ich war letzte Woche im Außendienst. Kannst du mich kurz auf den neuesten Stand bringen?
Moderation: [seufzt] Also gut. Wir haben einen leichten Anstieg in den Verkäufen in der Region Süd. Sabine, mach bitte weiter.
Sabine: Genau. Besonders gut lief es bei unseren neuen Modellen. Die Kampagne scheint zu greifen. Allerdings haben wir in Norddeutschland einen Rückgang verzeichnet.
Klaus: Woran liegt das? Haben wir dort irgendwelche besonderen Probleme?
Sabine: Es sieht so aus, als ob unser Hauptkonkurrent dort eine aggressive Preiskampagne fährt. Das müssen wir im Auge behalten.
Moderation: Das ist ein guter Punkt. Wir sollten unsere Preisstrategie in dieser Region überprüfen. Thomas, kannst du das übernehmen?
Thomas: Ja, klar. Ich werde die Daten analysieren und nächste Woche berichten.
Moderation: Danke, Thomas. Gibt es noch etwas zu den Verkaufszahlen?
Sabine: Ja, wir sollten vielleicht auch über die Rückmeldungen unserer Kunden sprechen. Da gab es einige Beschwerden über Lieferverzögerungen.
Peter: Das stimmt. Ich hatte letzte Woche ein paar schwierige Gespräche deswegen.
Moderation: Gut, dann lassen Sie uns das auf die Agenda setzen. Wir müssen herausfinden, wo die Probleme liegen und wie wir sie beheben können.
Klaus: Vielleicht sollten wir den Logistikpartner wechseln? Ich habe gehört, dass es da einige günstigere und zuverlässigere Anbieter gibt.
Moderation: Das könnten wir in Betracht ziehen. Klaus, kannst du das recherchieren und uns nächste Woche deine Empfehlungen vorstellen?
Klaus: Ja, mache ich.
Moderation: Perfekt. Als nächstes auf der Liste haben wir die neue Marketingstrategie. Lisa, bist du bereit?
Lisa: Ja, ich habe die Präsentation vorbereitet. Einen Moment... [Geräusche von Laptop-Tastatur] Also, unser Ziel ist es, die Marke in den sozialen Medien stärker zu positionieren.
Peter: Hast du konkrete Ideen, wie wir das umsetzen können?
Lisa: Ja, wir könnten Influencer-Marketing ausprobieren und gezielte Werbeanzeigen schalten. Außerdem plane ich eine Reihe von Webinaren.
Sabine: Das klingt vielversprechend. Hast du auch ein Budget dafür?
Lisa: Ja, ich habe eine grobe Schätzung erstellt. Wir müssten das allerdings noch im Detail durchgehen.
Moderation: Dann lass uns das für nächste Woche einplanen. Wir müssen sicherstellen, dass wir die Ressourcen effektiv nutzen.
Thomas: Ich hätte noch eine Frage zu den Webinaren. Wie wollt ihr die Zielgruppe dafür erreichen?
Lisa: Wir werden über unsere Newsletter, Social Media und unsere Website dafür werben. Zudem denke ich über Partnerschaften mit Fachzeitschriften nach.
Moderation: Klingt gut. Damit sind wir soweit durch mit den wichtigsten Punkten. Gibt es sonst noch etwas Dringendes?
Sabine: Ja, ich wollte noch das Thema Mitarbeiterschulungen ansprechen. Da gibt es einige neue Anforderungen.
Moderation: Danke für den Hinweis, Sabine. Das ist wichtig. Lass uns dafür einen separaten Termin festlegen.
[Hintergrundgeräusche, Gemurmel]
Moderation: Bevor wir weitermachen, möchte ich darauf hinweisen, dass wir unsere Ziele für das nächste Quartal klären müssen. Hat jemand Vorschläge?
Peter: Ich denke, wir sollten uns auf die Steigerung der Online-Verkäufe konzentrieren. Der Trend geht eindeutig in diese Richtung.
Klaus: Da stimme ich zu. Aber wir sollten auch sicherstellen, dass unsere Infrastruktur dem erhöhten Traffic gewachsen ist. Wir hatten letzte Woche einen kleinen Serverausfall.
Moderation: Guter Punkt, Klaus. Thomas, kannst du das mit der IT-Abteilung besprechen und uns ein Update geben?
Thomas: Ja, ich werde das in die Wege leiten und sicherstellen, dass wir auf den Anstieg vorbereitet sind.
Lisa: Ich wollte noch etwas zur Kundenbetreuung hinzufügen. Wir haben einige Beschwerden über die Erreichbarkeit unseres Support-Teams erhalten.
Moderation: Das ist wichtig. Wie können wir die Situation verbessern? Gibt es konkrete Vorschläge?
Sabine: Vielleicht sollten wir die Arbeitszeiten des Support-Teams verlängern und zusätzliche Schulungen anbieten, um die Effizienz zu erhöhen.
Peter: Ja, und wir könnten auch ein Ticket-System einführen, um die Anfragen besser zu verfolgen und schneller zu bearbeiten.
Moderation: Gute Ideen. Lisa, kannst du das weiterverfolgen und uns einen Plan vorstellen?
Lisa: Natürlich, ich werde mich darum kümmern.
Moderation: Dann hätten wir das. Kommen wir zu den neuen Produkten. Gibt es hier Neuigkeiten?
Klaus: Ja, wir arbeiten an einem neuen Türgriff, der antibakterielle Eigenschaften hat. Die ersten Prototypen sehen vielversprechend aus.
Peter: Das klingt spannend. Wie ist der Zeitplan dafür?
Klaus: Wenn alles gut läuft, könnten wir in drei Monaten mit der Produktion beginnen. Allerdings müssen wir noch einige Tests durchführen.
Moderation: Super, halt uns bitte auf dem Laufenden. Gibt es noch weitere Themen zu den neuen Produkten?
Sabine: Wir sollten auch die neuen Farboptionen für unsere aktuellen Modelle besprechen. Kunden haben nach mehr Vielfalt gefragt.
Moderation: Gute Idee. Thomas, kannst du das Design-Team einbeziehen und Vorschläge ausarbeiten?
Thomas: Ja, ich werde das weitergeben und nächste Woche berichten.
Moderation: Dann hätten wir die wichtigsten Punkte abgedeckt. Gibt es sonst noch etwas?
[Gemurmel und Diskussion im Hintergrund]
Peter: Mir ist noch etwas eingefallen. Wir sollten unsere Lagerbestände überprüfen. Es gab Berichte über Engpässe bei einigen Materialien.
Sabine: Ja, ich habe auch von Problemen gehört. Vielleicht sollten wir unsere Bestellprozesse optimieren.
Moderation: Gute Idee. Klaus, kannst du das analysieren und uns Vorschläge machen?
Klaus: Ja, ich werde mir das anschauen und eine Lösung erarbeiten.
Moderation: Perfekt, dann sind wir für heute durch. Vielen Dank an alle und bis nächste Woche.
[Verabschiedungen, Stühle werden gerückt, Meeting endet]
Moderation: Halt, bevor wir gehen, fällt mir ein, dass wir noch das Feedback der letzten Messe auswerten müssen. Wer hat die Ergebnisse?
Peter: Oh, das liegt bei mir. Einen Moment... Also, wir haben überwiegend positives Feedback erhalten, aber es gab auch einige Kritikpunkte.
Moderation: Welche Kritikpunkte wurden genannt?
Peter: Hauptsächlich ging es um unsere Präsentation. Einige fanden sie etwas unübersichtlich und nicht interaktiv genug.
Sabine: Vielleicht sollten wir beim nächsten Mal interaktive Elemente wie Touchscreens oder VR einsetzen.
Moderation: Das ist eine gute Idee. Lisa, kannst du das mit dem Messe-Team besprechen und uns Vorschläge unterbreiten?
Lisa: Ja, ich kümmere mich darum.
Moderation: Danke, Lisa. Gibt es sonst noch etwas, was wir besprechen sollten?
[Hintergrundgeräusche, Diskussionen]
Thomas: Ja, ich wollte noch anmerken, dass wir uns auch auf die kommenden Feiertage vorbereiten müssen. Da gibt es immer einen Anstieg bei den Bestellungen.
Moderation: Richtig, das sollten wir nicht vergessen. Sabine, kannst du dafür sorgen, dass wir ausreichend Personal einplanen?
Sabine: Ja, ich werde das organisieren.
Moderation: Gut, dann sind wir wirklich durch für heute. Vielen Dank und bis nächste Woche.
[Verabschiedungen, Stühle werden gerückt, Meeting endet]